when you're streaming when you're when
you're doing the
the creative work do you feel lonely so
a bunch of creators talk about sort of
the
it's it's counter-intuitive because
you're famous now
you know
sort of not quite but
we're very lucky to have each other so
is that the source of the the comfort
and the
like is there some sense where it's
isolating
to have these personalities they have to
do to always be having fun being wild
and so on
or is it actually the opposite like is
it a source of comfort to know that
there's so many cool people out there
that are giving you their love and
it started as a source of comfort
because it started with a very small
community who would be something it
would be around 200 to 300 viewers and
you know only like 30 to 40 of them
would actually chat actively so you felt
like it was a community not an audience
so you like knew them personally almost
yeah exactly and it was people who were
interested in chess um and i would
really enjoy that and then as you know
we started growing bigger the audience
kind of changed where
they're not there for you personally
they're there while you're entertaining
um and it
changed for me and i ended up being a
lot more self-conscious of things online
and started even thinking of myself more
like a product than a human being when
i'm online because i had to brand yes
exactly otherwise you just start taking
everything personally that people
comment about you and it's based off a
very small
i see so it's almost a kind of defense
mechanism exactly
and it took time to get enough
because even if you have tough skin
eventually it gets to you when you're
online every single day listening to you
know thousands of people's feedback on
you
i think the loneliest part of being
creator is going through burnout which
everyone is just bound to happen
which is why i think we're very lucky
that we have each other because right
it's a numbers game and you're viral and
trendy at one point and then you have to
fall
and then there's months where you're
just grinding and i just every day
i'm like andrea we're relevant that's
where i'm glad that's that's really like
the worst part of being creative and
figuring out how to get over that hump
it makes me very grateful that i have my
sister because i know that i'm not the
only person going through it
and
yeah i know that most of my creator
friends feel very lonely in that process
because they don't have someone who's
their family and their business partner
and they're working by each other side
by side you kind of tie in your
self-worth to your job and your content
and maybe even more extremely than other
jobs because you also are
the entire company in the entire product
so when things are going well or when
things are not you just need to be
careful to not reflect like oh i am
doing bad i am better other than the
trends have now changed there's outside
things we're going to keep going and
this is just the normal waves which is
how we think about it now and also just
about are we enjoying it this is this
what we want to make but we were stuck
in the the camp for a while when we
10xed our viewership um after the
pandemic because people were home and
playing chess and then of course that
dropped by like 70 and then you see that
and you're trying your best
and you just kind of have to deal with
it and be like okay i'm just going to
keep persevering and
maybe it'll get better that's so
fascinating i mean this is a
struggle
of sorts in the 21st century
of like how to be an artist how to be a
creator how to be an interesting mind
in response to this algorithm i'm
telling you turning off views and likes
is really good i don't look at twitch
views for that reason and i get obsessed
with the numbers too and i know andrea
does but for me
what i try now is to be more focused in
the moment but andrea somehow can do it
even with the views
so you just you get you have fun with it
it like oh number one i'm too much of
like a given to the temporary
satisfaction like i like seeing i'd like
knowing that if something happens right
now viewership is going to boost by a
couple hundred and seeing that i'm right
of course but what about when the
viewers started exactly well and i
always like you just have this intuition
now and but i think also the reason that
it doesn't affect me so much is when we
first started our content journey we
were only twitch streamers and we our
livelihood were based on twitch viewers
but now like i've learned how to recycle
that content into like youtube and
shorts and other things where i know
like okay if this stream does badly
there's so many more things you can do
that also just have a much larger output
so it doesn't get to me as much as it
did
do you ever feel that with your podcast
or do you feel like it's been authentic
since the start no so
there's there's a million things to say
there so one
is there's a reason
i stopped taking a salary at mit
and moved to texas is i wanted my bank
account to go to zero because i do my
best with my back against the wall so
one of the comforts i have is i don't
care if this podcast is popular or not
i wanted to not be popular so i don't
want it to make money failing lex yeah i
want i want to i mean i just do best
when i'm um
more desperate that's like one thing to
say seems like a reoccurring theme with
how you build up your greatest work
which is honestly very respectable
yeah so uh uh i thank you that's just
like uh i would recommend it
right
thank you for finding it don't try it
the silver lining for an unhealthy um
mental state um
but the other thing is i was very
conscious just like with chess and those
kinds of things
that
i love numbers and i i would be if i
paid attention
if i tried to be
somebody at their best like a mr beast
who
really pays attention to numbers i would
just not
i'd be become destroyed by it
the highs and lows of it and i just
don't think i'll be creating the best
work
uh possible
but
one of the i mean they're
one of the big benefits of a podcast
it's listeners
and there's an intimacy with the voice
and i think
that is much more stable
and a deeper and a more meaningful
connection
than youtube youtube is a fickle
mistress
it's like it's a weird drug that like
uh it really wants you very addicting
feedback loops when you have a video
that's number one out of ten yeah oh my
god the the adrenaline you get and then
the the thing i really don't like also
is the world
uh like will introduce you
as a person that has a video on youtube
with some x number of views like the
world wants you to be addicted to these
numbers
because they associate it with having
done a good job yeah because that's what
people think views are even if it's not
right and because and primarily because
they don't have any other signal
of what's a good job i think the much
better signal is people they're close to
you your family your colleagues that say
wow that was cool i listened to that
that was really i didn't know this this
was really powerful this is really
moving and so on but definitely i'm not
terrified of numbers because i i feel
like just like i said
i'd rather be um
i would rather be a stanley kubrick
right you you'd rather create
great art like
not to be pretentious but the best
possible thing you can create whatever
the beauty that's the capacity for
creating beauty that's in you i would
like to maximize that and i feel like
for some people like mr beast i think
those are perfectly aligned
because he just loves the most epic
thing possible but not for everybody i
think there's a lot of people for whom
that's not perfectly aligned
and so i'm definitely one of those and
i'm still really confused why anybody
listens to this anyway
um
but that's also something i guess you're
trying to find
trying to figure out i i get very afraid
of ever becoming someone who just makes
junk food content where
you can't stop while you're in the
moment and it has all of your attention
but when you're done it didn't really
bring any value to your life which is
something that i think the algorithm
still does really reward
and making sure that as we are learning
how to create better content it's still
something that is going to be meaningful
long term
well ultimately you know you inspire a
lot of young people
uh this
yeah those are the best when i get
messages from people who are like i
played you a year ago and my rating was
1400 and now i'm 1900 i'd like to
challenge you again it's a 14 year old
writing a former email those things are
always very very fun to get and even
just outside of chess it's just
empowering to see and like for young
women too to see that kind of thing i
mean you guys are um being yourself
and making money from being yourself and
having fun and like growing as human
beings
which i think is really inspiring for
people to see so in that sense that's
really rewarding and then like the way i
think about it is um
there is some benefit of doing
entertaining type of stuff
so that
you get the
um
kind of like mr beast does with
philanthropy right the bigger mr beast
becomes the more effective he is at
actually doing positive impact on the
world so right those things are tied uh
tied together but of course with with
podcasts
you guys well maybe you have these kinds
of tense things but
what kind of ideas what kind of people
do you platform
what kind of person
um
what kind of human being do you want to
be
because you're actually are becoming a
person
and um
a set of ideas in front of the public
eye and you have to ask yourself that
question really hard like really
seriously because uh if you're doing
stuff in private
you have the complete luxuries to try
[ __ ] out right
i think you have less of a luxury to try
[ __ ] out because the internet can be
vicious and punishing you for trying
[ __ ] out and do you think that's
sometimes a bad thing where you have
less freedom to make mistakes
yeah you have two choices so one you put
up a wall and say i don't give a [ __ ]
what people think
i don't like doing that because i like
being fragile to the world keeping my
sort of wearing my heart on my sleeve
uh or the other one yeah you have to be
you have to
you have to actually think through what
you're gonna say
you have to think of like
what do i believe you have to be more
serious about
um what you put out there
it's annoying
but it's also actually you should have
always been doing that
you should be deliberate with your
actions and your words
um
but i don't know it's uh
but some of it it's such a balance
because
some of my favorite people are brilliant
people that allow themselves to act
ridiculous and be silly elon musk who's
become a good friend is the silliest
human of all i mean he's incredibly
uh brilliant and productive and so on
but allows themselves to be silly
and that that's also inspiring to people
like you don't have to be perfect
you don't have to
you can be a weird a giant weird mess
and it's okay that's a it's a balance i
think when you start to delve into
political topics into topics that
really get tense for people then you
have to be a little bit more careful and
deliberate
um but it's also wise to stay stay the
hell away from those topics in general
uh like i mentioned to you offline
somebody i
have been debating with i want to talk
to your nas kuryakin on the chessboard
because
you know chess is just a game but
throughout
the history of the 20th century it was
played
between the russians and the americans
and so on where
they were war
cold or hot war
and those are interesting
those those are interesting um
conversations to be had at the olympics
and so on it's not just a game it's some
sense it's like a mini war
and so i have to decide whether i want
to talk to to him or not and those kinds
of things you have to make those kinds
of decisions
for now you guys are not playing chess
with with donald trump or obama or so on
we are not right now no
how long is a stream like a few hours
right now they're two to three hours
when i was first streaming i'd stream
for like six hours a day a day at least
usually yeah for like seven six to seven
days a week just like a talking one no i
would be playing chess the entire time
while talking and
when i started streaming uh
that's kind of how everybody blows up on
twitch you're just putting in crazy
hours and you're always there it's not
about making the best content it's about
letting people feel like they're hanging
out with you and just being on as much
as you can but i ended up feeling very
burnt out because it's hard to be your
best self when you're in front of a
camera for that long because you do
get scared of going into places where
you want to learn but you might not be
the best in because it's harder to learn
in public than do something that like
yeah we're better than 99 of our viewers
at chess so that's a lot less scary than
trying to
play a game that you're bad at or
discuss topics that you're interested in
yeah be
have the beginner's mind and be dumb at
something right yeah which is where the
fun is and you get to learn together but
people punish you for it on the internet
um what about you
andrea yeah i think like alex said at
the beginning when we were grinding a
lot you don't really even have time for
much of a private life because you're
streaming
every hour of your life and people want
it like
the appeal of streamers is called like
being parasocial where you feel like
they're your friend and they like it
because they want you to share
everything about your life
um really the main challenge for me
at first when trying to prioritize
uh
quantity over quality which we're not
doing anymore was realizing that i can't
turn everything i'm interested in every
passion into content
before i'm like well i must stream more
but i like music and i like playing
piano and i like reading into these
topics and i like fitness and then i try
to live stream all of it and that's just
at some point it's like just enjoy your
time off for those hobbies and
prioritize what you're good at because
that's just going to be better for the
channel overall so that was a learning
lesson for sure it's nice because there
are some intersections when i have tried
new things that i really enjoy and it
pays off but that's more uh less often
so it's more like you can be yourself
but only specific parts of yourself
online
and the rest sometimes it's nice to just
keep private and
feel that you could just
give it your 100
freedom
see i i i feel like
i try to be the exact same person
on podcasts as in private life i really
don't like
hiding anything but you're also a
generalist right where you have people
with all topics for us we build our
audience off of very specific things so
people sometimes feel like even at the
start when we started playing less chess
they're like i subbed for chess why are
you not playing chess
exactly people are tuning in for an
interesting conversation on a bunch of
topics so like the more you are yourself
the better it is but it is very hard
when you build your brand on like one
type of gaming content
build your brand
uh i but yeah the way you become a
journalist is you slowly expand
it's like uh like uh
expanded checkers
i guess that's the downward uh
maybe poker poker yeah exactly poker but
also just the ideas the space of ideas
and one of the cool things about chess
is when you're talking over the
chessboard you're it's a kind of podcast
you know
that is actually an idea we've had with
playing chess while also doing a podcast
and talking with people it's kind of
like an icebreaker we're also focusing
on the game at the same time but you
know we are slowly evolving and we're
doing more things like one thing we
wanted to do is spend less time in front
of the computer so now we're doing a
chess travel show where we go to
different countries and look at the
chess culture so it actually feels like
we're doing things that we would want to
do and explore anyway
and maybe it's not as much in the idea
space which we both enjoy and do a lot
in our own free time but in the
sharing cool experiences with our
audience that we actually want to do
what do you look forward to going we're
going to romania um
on september 9th and i think this is the
most exciting for me because we're going
back to you know the country where our
entire family's from
where our grandmother taught our dad who
taught us how to play chess it has a
very strong chess culture so it'll be
very unique to go back and see
how everything is when we haven't been
back for a very long time and for
romanians like it's very rare when
there's like a famous romanian who
accomplishes something which is why like
right now andrew tate's the most famous
romanian but he's banned for a bad
reason exactly and there's like
something very special about romanian
pride and when we meet fellow romanians
in the us like it's just an amazing
connection and like i hear the way my
dad talk about like for example uh nadia
who was a famous romanian gymnast and
he's like yeah like romania we sucked at
everything but when she won the olympics
for gymnasts every kid on the street was
doing gymnastics because it's very rare
that they make it to that level of
success i'm not saying that we're super
successful super famous but it is really
cool to meet other romanians through
chess because it's a very special bond
you you you feel
like it's a community and like you
belong yeah you can't get that anywhere
else
you